quand tu vas des piquer
tu sais qu'il y a un point de chaînette
donc tu vas le chercher à l'intérieur tu
enlève un petit peu parce que le fil va
peut-être être usé il peut être cuit
c'est comme le corps tu tires dessus et
normalement ça s'enlève jusqu'au bout 39
ans que Sophie le docteur Sophie plutôt
travaille dans la maison et depuis 1998
elle est à la tête de la clinique des
poupées le seul et unique service
d'urgence au monde Sophie en remet sur
pied près de 500 par an son tour de main
est inégalable même si elle dit ne pas
savoir faire les miracles on peut
réparer un bébé 4 ans pourquoi parce que
ce bébé chéri existe encore aujourd'hui
par contre on pourra peut-être pas
réparer un bébé qui a trois quatre ans
parce qu'il a été fait que deux ans et
aujourd'hui on le fabrique plus donc on
a plus de stock de pièces détachées mais
docteur Sophie entrer dans l'entreprise
à 16 ans voit poindre la retraite à
l'horizon quelques années vont encore
s'écouler mais autant de compétences et
de savoir-faire ne peuvent pas se
transmettre en quelques semaines il
fallait donc agir
c'est quelque chose en fait sur que j'ai
pensé depuis que j'ai anticipé depuis
pas mal de temps on en a aussi
longuement parlé avec Sophie lors de nos
je dirais débrief quotidiens et
finalement je dirais le temps arrivant
assez vite il a fallu je dirais statuer
de manière aussi assez vite pour
prolonger en tous les cas le
savoir-faire de Sophie
alors avec l'accord de son groupe
allemand qui est la partie la société
tourangelle s'est mise en quête de la
successeur et départ Pôle emploi par un
organisme de formation par une agence
d'intérim et la trouver la perle rare
Aurore elle fait son entrée dans la
famille elle fait son internat auprès du
docteur Sophie comme ses collègues liste
en plaisantant c'est un rêve tout
éveillé pour la jeune femme
et de prendre la succession de Sophie
vous allez devenir la responsable de la
clinique dans quelques années
c'est vrai c'est vrai après j'y pense
pas trop pour l'instant parce que
c'est tout frais donc voilà c'est un
métier pas comme les autres
et on voit pas on voit pas tous les
jours la même chose tous les poupons
voilà sont différents donc
vous êtes une salarié heureuse oui oui
ça faisait tellement longtemps que je
cherchais
les poupées fatiguées seront bon
toujours bien soignés en Indre-et-Loire
la clinique ne va pas fermée c'est bien
ça
c'est bon